simplify the rational expression and
state the domain so we have a rational
expression here one rack one expression
being divided by another one and so to
simplify it i am guessing that we will
have to factor this top expression and
this bottom expression and there's
probably common factors that we might be
able to cancel out but we have to be
very careful about how we do them so
let's factor each of these so you may or
may not remember how to how to factor
ratio how to factor quadratic
expressions that have a non-a non-one
coefficient out here so this will be
practice in that and we go into the
rationale for why it works in those
videos where we first learn to factor
rational expressions and they're in this
playlist but just as a reminder what you
want to do is you want to split this
middle term you want to split the first
degree term into two terms you want to
group it one of them with this 2x
squared and one of it with the 20 and
you want to group it into two terms so
that the coefficients of the two terms
when you take their product is the same
thing as 2 times 20. so you want to
break let me write it over here you want
to break
13x you want to break it into an ax plus
a bx
where
a
times b is equal to two times twenty
and we show why this works in a previous
video so a times b needs to be equal to
forty and they and a plus b needs to be
equal to 13. so let's just think about
the factors of 40.
1 and 40 are not going to work
2 and 20 are not going to work they
don't add up to 13 3 and 3 well 3
doesn't go into 40. 4
and 10 does not work
five and eight so if we take
five times eight that does equal
that does equal forty and then five plus
eight does equal 13 so that's looking
pretty good so let's split up the 13x
along those lines so we get 2x squared
plus 5
plus 5x plus
8x
is plus 20 plus 20. so all i did is i
split up this 13x into a 5x plus an 8x
and now we can group these two terms we
can group these two terms and then let's
go down over here
let's go down over here and do the same
thing in the denominator so let's get do
the same exact thing in the denominator
once again we want to find two numbers
that add up to 17 and whose product is 2
times 30 or 60. so if we look at the
factors of 60
1 and 60 don't work they don't add up to
17 or if you took the negative 1 and
negative 60. you're not going to have
negative numbers because they would have
to be the same sign since this is
positive and then they would add up they
would give you a negative value over
here so we have to deal with positive
numbers 2 and 2 and 30 don't work
3 and
15 remember we want to get to 2 times 30
we want to get to 60. 3 times 15 sorry
not 3 times fifteen
three times twenty three times twenty
doesn't work
they don't there the product is sixty
but doesn't add up to seventeen four
times fifteen
does not work
five times 12.
5 times 12 is 60. so that is that works
that's the same thing as 2 times 30 it
equals 60 and 5 plus 12 is 17. so that's
looking pretty good so let's separate
this out into 2x squared plus 5x plus
12x
plus 30 plus 30 and then we can group
them we can group them like this and
then let's see how we can simplify each
of these expressions this top expression
over here we have a common factor of x
so this top expression over here we can
factor out an x out of this so this
becomes
x times
and 2x squared divided by x is 2x 5x
divided by x when you have the x
factored out that is just five
so this first term is x times two x plus
five and then plus
over here we can factor out a four four
is divisible into both eight x and into
twenty so let's factor out a four so
this is four times
8x with a 4 factored out is now just 2x
and then 20 with the 4 factored out is
just a 5.
and then let's do the bottom over here
i'm kind of doing them both
simultaneously in parallel
the bottom over here we can factor out
an x out of this expression so this is x
times
once again 2x plus 5
plus this expression over here we can
factor out looks like we could
factor out a 6 out of both 12x and 30.
so let's factor out a 6
and then 12x 12x divided by 6 is 2x
2x and then 30 divided by 6 is 5.
x plus five
and so we can simplify this we can
factor out from this term we can factor
out a two x plus five from this term we
can factor out a two x plus five so if
we factor out two x plus five from both
of these so we're factoring out a two x
plus five
you're left with an x and a plus four
you're left with an x plus four
and then down here we can factor out a
two x plus five
down here we can factor out a two 2x let
me make it in that same color we can
factor out a 2x plus 5.
so we're literally just factoring out a
2x plus 5 and we're left with an x plus
6. we're just doing the distributive
property in reverse over here x plus 6.
now you might be tempted to say hey look
i have a 2x plus 5 in the numerator 2x
plus 5 in the denominator let me just
cancel them out really fast and i would
have simplified the expression we have
to be very careful because we first need
to think about the domain because if we
just simplify this expression and we
start include things in the simplified
domain that weren't included in the
original functions domain we've actually
changed the expression or we've changed
the function so we have to be very
careful that even when we simplify it we
keep the domain the same so what's the
domain of this thing
what's going to be all real numbers
except the ones that make the
denominator equal to zero and what are
the numbers that make the denominator
equal to zero well the denominator is
equal to zero if x plus six is equal to
zero or two x plus 5 is equal to 0.
and x plus 6 if x plus 6 is 0 that that
means that x is negative 6 subtract 6
from both sides over here we can
subtract 5 from both sides so you get 2x
is equal to negative 5. divide both
sides by 2 you get x is equal to
negative 5 halves
so the domain of this expression right
over here the domain
the domain of this expression
if we could call this a function if we
defined it as you know f of x is equal
to all of this the domain of it
the domain is going to be all real
numbers all
real numbers
all real numbers except
except negative six and negative five
halves except negative six
and
negative five halves these will make
this expression undefined it will make
this denominator equal to zero
now we can simplify it as long as we
keep this denominator so now if we
assume that we're never going to see a
negative 5 halves then 2x plus 5 is
never going to be equal 0 and so we can
divide the numerator and denominator by
that value cancelling it out and so the
simplified expression is what's left
over x plus 4 over x plus 6
x plus 4 over x plus 6 but we have to
keep the same domain if we didn't write
this here you'd say okay the only thing
that would make this thing 0 is x is
equal to negative 6. we have to remember
this is a simplified version of that in
order for these to be identical
expressions or maybe identical function
definitions they need to have the exact
same domain so the domain for this
simplified expression has to be the same
as the original all real numbers except
negative 6 and negative 5 halves